متى زال وحظرت جها دعوات الدول لها بسرعه
اعطاء ضوئها الاخضر لتسليم دباباتها
ليوبارت الكيف بعد ما اشترط من دافوس
المستشار الالماني اوليف ان تبعت واشنطن
دباباتها اولا لكيف حتى يسمح بمشاركه
دبابات بلاده في الحرب يلتقي اليوم في
برلين وزير الدفاع الجديد بوريستوريا
والدفاع الجوي او قادفات الصواريخ
المتعدده الانظمه الالمانيه الحديث
التصريحات الامريكيه تذهب في الاتجاه ذاته
للعدوان الروسي والدفاع عن اراضيه السياده
اود ان اشكر الحكومه الالمانيه على كل ما
فعلته لتعزيز الدفاع عن النفس في اوكرانيا
الذي وعد بمزيد من الاسلحه الثقيله
والحديثه السويد بدورها قررت تزويد اكياس
بمركبه قتاليه وصواريخ مضاده للدبابات
امام هذا التصعيد الاوروبي الغربي لم
يتاخر رد موسكو التي اكدت على لسانديمات
اوكرانيا بمزيد من الاسلحه يعني بلوغ
الصراع مستوى جديد